[Music]  one year ago the commission adopted a  new industrial strategy  with one main objective enable eu  industry  to lead the twin green and digital  transitions  and become even more competitive  globally  much has changed since march 2020 but  our ambitions have not  the transformation to a more sustainable  digital  resilient and competitive economy has  only increased  we want our startups smes larger  companies  to not only keep pace with that change  but also  drive it our single market is our  greatest asset for europe's recovery  today we take actions to make our single  market better equipped for crises  map out strategic dependencies and  possible measures  to enhance europe's ability to preserve  our interests  while remaining fully engaged globally  increase collaboration across industries  and support the business case  for the twin green and digital  transitions  [Music]  you